welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you
currently stuck in doors and occupying
your home and you really need to check
out this new Netflix thriller the
occupant has just dropped on the
platform today and as soon as I saw that
Mario Casas was starring in it I had to
check it out he was part of the cast in
one of the best thrillers I've ever seen
called the invisible guest which you
should definitely check out if you
haven't similar to that movie the
occupant is full of twists and turns and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down everything you need to
know about the film and its ending there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
and if you enjoy it then please give it
a thumbs up
without the way thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into our
breakdown of the occupant okay so the
occupant is a Spanish movie that has
titled hogar in its native language this
roughly translates to home and the movie
is pretty much laced with the question
of what truly makes one is it the bricks
and mortar that create the environment
that the occupiers live in or the
occupiers themselves is it the symbol of
status that it provides and can we truly
ever keep our home due to time passing
on and the circle of life it's something
that the occupant poses to audiences and
though the protagonist falls towards the
more material aspects it does leave the
audience to ask ourselves what really
matters we follow Xavier a one
successful marketing executive that is
long past his prime the movie opens with
him interviewing for a job and
showcasing his best work an
advertisement on a home with a strap
line of the life you deserve
similar to the advertisement itself
Xavier was once highly regarded and
loved by many however as with all things
time has made him lose his shine in
Javier's mind he deserves a life where
he's at the top of the game and living
comfortably in contrast to this he
struggles even gaining entry-level jobs
due to prejudices and feels like the
world has wronged him in some ways I
think the film really comments on
society and how we treat the elderly in
light of the current crisis that is
going on
many people are questioning whether the
economy is worth more than our more
senior members of society and it feels
like we failed them in some ways by even
question
this they paved the way stabilized
civilization and now that they're viewed
as having no use they get cast to the
side it's something that the movie
grapples with and though Xavier is only
middle-aged it does show how we may all
be doomed to fall into this trap one day
if we don't change how things work after
a year of unemployment
Xavier can no longer afford his home and
thus he and his family are forced to
leave it they move into a dilapidated
shabby apartment when the taps drip all
of the time and I'll get into the
meaning behind that later in the video
it starts off a chain of events that
have major consequences and the movie
centers around Xavier trying to win back
the life he views himself as deserving
one day he discovers that he still has a
set of keys to his old home and he
begins stalking the family that has
moved in there
slowly he tries to get closer to them in
any way that it can and they become his
obsession the film is very much about
trying to regain the things that one is
lost and for Xavier this represents a
number of elements including the
property to the youth that the family
have they are pretty much the younger
happier versions of his own family and
both families mirror each other in many
ways I'm sure one day we will all be in
a place where we look at people who are
in a position that we once were with
complete envy it becomes easy to
sympathize with Javier's jealousy and
often feels like time is slipping away
like sand in our hands the stronger we
try to hold on to it the faster it slips
away and we watch as Xavier slowly
becomes more and more desperate now one
of the most interesting aspects of the
film that truly speaks to Javier's
personality is that his career is based
in advertising because Xavier lived so
long in the world of selling dreams
he is an idealized view of the world
advertisements and commercials are
created in such a way that they makers
always want more and more their purpose
is to push the narrative that the grass
is always greener and what we have isn't
enough this is how they work because of
living in this world for so long
xavier is unable to appreciate what he
truly has he has a son and wife that are
both willing to do whatever they can to
please him but he Beus them is not being
good enough he hates that his son is
obese and views the other family as
having a child that's bit inactive he
views Tomas the father of the family as
being more successful in his and the
movie truly speaks to how people have
become
we live in a world where people only put
out the perfect versions of themselves
on social media and thus it becomes easy
to compare and believe that we aren't
good enough Xavier is obsessed with
materials and even though he can't
afford it he still refuses to sell his
BMW at several points due to the image
that are portrays to the world of
success this is of course mirrored in
our online life in which many of us try
to appear like we are constantly winning
in order to keep up with others who
appear the same way even though we know
it's all fake on our end and theirs we
still fall victim to it and it's such an
interesting character study that makes
this a brilliant watch he unearths
Thomas was an alcoholic that almost
caused a fatal crash with his family
after drunk driving
Tomas attends a a meetings and this is
where Javier sparks up a friendship with
him now there are two key differences
between the characters here that
indicate why one is happy and why the
other isn't Tomas nearly lost his family
and thus he will do whatever he can to
hold on to them he is really working for
it even if it doesn't always work
however Javier will do whatever he can
to get his old life back even if it
means losing his family he refuses to
give up the status that he once had
whilst Tomas will constantly try over
and over to give up his obsession with
alcohol in order to hold on to the
things that are dearest to him both want
to change though and prove that they are
better than others think they are and
thus they find some kinship in their
stories even when Thomas tells Javier
that things aren't always sunshine and
roses he still ignores it because he has
this core aspect built into his mind
that there is this idealized version of
life Tomas has a job that he gained
through his father and all owning a
successful company and similar to Javier
he wishes to be at the top however
Javier doesn't just want to take
Thomas's belongings he wants to be him
and what he represents and unlike him he
will go to Machiavellian ends to do it
he views the apartment is making him
above all and is actually imagery that I
found almost signifying that he viewed
himself as godlike looking overall even
controlling life and death this shot is
later reversed with him hiding behind
the tree having to be obscured whereas
up top he is able to proudly look
overall I don't know if I'm reading too
much into that but but yeah it's just
something I thought whilst watching the
film Javier crashes his car to use the
opportunity to send himself an email
from Thomas's phone that
used to frame him later he's made to
carry out perverted things by a janitor
that recognized him and Thomas's wife
begins to suspect him of falling back
into old habits
she calls Xavier to tell him to stay
away from Thomas but he brings up the
email and things slowly become more and
more twisted Xavier begins gaslighting
Thomas and confronts him at work in
order to get him to lash out with
bruises on his face he returns to
Thomas's wife Laura and makes her
believe that he's dangerous
Xavier gives her a pepper spray can that
he's laced with peanuts which Carter is
allergic to he leaves his wife and
slowly Xavier starts to put the pieces
in place for his end game which is
disciplined Thomas he manipulates him
into returning to the apartment and she
sprays him with the pepper spray can
which shuts down his body xavier returns
to the apartment to cover the crime up
and he says the thomas that he doesn't
deserve them before suffocating him
which of course ties into the tagline of
the life you deserve in the end xavier
gains a job which he was initially
supposed to be an intern for earlier in
the movie and because of his connection
to laura and a father's company he's
able to secure a massive advertising
deal
Javier's ex-wife turns up asking for the
truth as she's pieced it all together
she states that she will tell the police
and he will end up in a Cell that makes
the home he despised seem like a mansion
Xavier calls a bluff and says that he
will use his son's trust fund and their
home and hiring a lawyer to defend him
Javier's wife Marga in the end doesn't
do it and it really shows the dichotomy
of the two characters Javier would risk
everything he can to gain a house
property and status
whereas Marga will do whatever she can
to make sure her child is okay which
Javier doesn't really seem to care about
the movie ends with him in a giant new
home with Thomas's family as his own the
entire property is pristine and it truly
seems like he has achieved it all
however the tap starts to drip similar
to his run-down apartment and this
symbolizes that he will not find
happiness here because he has placed
value into material items instead of
people he didn't care about putting his
own son at risk because all he wanted
was status but in the long run this is a
hollow thing that will not make him
happy the house itself in the final
shots though expansive seems completely
empty and devoid of life this is similar
to how Xavier will eventually feel
because
tossed everything away in order to climb
back up the social ladder Xavier in life
has already been at the top of this and
he has seen how easily it can all be
taken away
thus it isn't likely that it will remain
here for him Xavier is now back into the
same circumstances that caused his
downfall however he has a son and
ex-wife that hate and despise him they
truly loved him at one point no matter
what home he provided and once the shell
that he is created with Lara starts to
fade away and his true face is revealed
a concealed lasting long it's a
brilliant message that tells us to
appreciate what we have and that the
grass isn't always greener everything
has its faults and there's no real joy
in material items Xavier has mistakenly
believed this and nurse it will lead to
him repeating the actions that we saw in
the film it's a truly haunting ending
that left me with goosebumps and the
message that we should all appreciate
what we have now before we get into the
review I just wanna let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the Star Wars
Skywalker saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the film in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of April
and the cell be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part ok so
what did I think of the film well
overall the occupant is an astonishing
film and I'm so glad that Netflix are
dropping some big movies at the moment
alongside the platform both are truly
astounding and I absolutely adored the
pair of them the iake print is
definitely one to watch right now as
it's perfectly crafted acted and it
carries a strong message that I think
works on a lot of levels I really
enjoyed it and I highly recommend that
you check out the movie and that's why
it gets a 9 out of 10 now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
occupant and what you took from it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of last week's big Netflix
release at the platform which is gonna
be linked at the end we talked about all
of the metaphors in that film and the
true meaning behind it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it there's a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with heavy spoilers so hopefully we
see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best now see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]